pfff quel âge entre la réalité et les
sentiments ça a été très très visible ou
tout blanc des années 2000 au moment de
la compétition qui verra jusqu'à
éliminer le premier à l'issue du premier
tour et un très fort sentiment
d'insécurité dans le pays avec
l'insécurité première préoccupation des
français
et cette réponse là va se dégonfler en
quelques mois nicolas sarkozy devenu
président ministre de l'intérieur dans
des proportions qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la réalité du refuge de la
délinquance maintenant les perceptions
sont aussi des faits sociaux dit on dans
mon métier
quand vous avez dans l' enquête qu'ils
aient à rendre publique par le figaro
quarante pour cent des gens qui se
disent dans la sécurité qui disent par
ailleurs ben je fais des détours gentil
importe au quotidien et si on y
réfléchit bien l'insécurité dans toutes
ses dimensions et une présence
incroyable dans notre vie quotidienne
avec des forts contrastes pour finir
avant de te laisser la parole entre les
zones urbaines et puis d'autres zones
qui sont